こんにちはドクター
はじめ皆さん今の時代ロボットがいて当たり前の時代になってきました
という意味でこの私ドクターはじめも日々研究を重ね努力をからねぇ
ついに完成したドクターズが作った最新型の ai ロボットを紹介したいと思います
ではおじいちゃんのこと
おいでん
こちらが私が20かけて開発した
伝説の以来の事 og
セックスシックスナインないんだ今日はよろしくお願いしますうわーん
いいいいいいいいいい
えっ
ha
素晴らしいロボットです完全前日心理型ロボットなので意識を持っているので人間
っぽい動作がかなりリアルなんですほとんど人間と言っても間違いない動きをしてくれ
ますそうですよね
4一瞬濃音でその姿勢から返事したのでちょっと実際がありました完全に人の心を持っ
た最新型のことはホージーシックな柄6ない汗
王子6シックスナイン nine このロボットとホッケーと言って
コミュニケーションをとるかといいますと
スマートフォンですこの og 失火階6ないのにスマートフォンを持たせることに
よって僕が指令を出すとそうするとその指令を見た大勢祝賀会6ないんだぜが大手紙
空席かがいないがその指令を実行することができるという心とちゃんといったことを
素直に動くっていう両方を兼ね備えた最強の ai ロボットでございますだけ今日は
この後
アクセル再発した og 6シックスナインナインの力を皆さんに見せていこうと思い
ますよ
王子しっくしくないね言うぞん
くろよん
すごいです疲れ様ですどうでした
いい感じです
とりわけますねっ
まあ星
魔界の県内分煙
せないようになっちゃってるのが全面てロマンスんですけどっ
ん
トマトスパキャンペン totes
をつくっていません
うん2
みなさんこんにちは
これじゃじゃあ上がっていない私は
ai ロボット王子6ない宿すないんです
よろしくお願い致しますお願いします
4日
ただ誇っている方はいませんか
[音楽]
誰かいっ
こちらに来てくださいとお子靴を脱ぐよっ
浴場に性愛道
3もう
扱うてクーラーだけも今でマッサージサンって言ってない澄んでて気持ち良かったん
ですか
マッサージ白い山なのでさあじゃちょっと僕いい
大量せいじゃなかったん
me
児童生徒あるアーレすごいふうちゃん神社
おいあなたは
日本の妖怪
パパに似てますなああああああああっ
白炭上げの調節がで顔認証ね
9キロは誰に醤油で視力がれ経済についてんぱいっていうのを気
すげー優秀なえーん
こっちもいいですねお前はちょっと
炎上
しがちですねああ
あっあぁああああ
rar
読みが通りますよはあああ
肩凝った f
さあ霊子っても買ってくるかたゴルフっても言っ誰か
カーター
たたえてくれませんか
始め様の
隣にいる
変な前髪ぬ奴 r
わかり私に入っ扱い方を叩け
っていう風に強いされるシャイで確かにするまだ
変わってきたと思ってな
[音楽]
さあ
喉が渇いたな
おい
そこのカッパの隣にいるちびムーン
ジュースをもってこい
じゃあ前素晴らしいねば社会になる
いやいやもう環境がちょっとは終わりましたねわかりたい
後ろの奴に
軽くキックしてくださいこれは僕のこのザッハー
こういうことねそう思い
下がれ
プー聞くされましたんですよ
外の落ち武者みたいな
髪型ので
だねぇ
大
3回回ってワンとんやっほぉ
そのままカレー
いつもしましたぜひだけを大
みんなで
これを拍手しろんか
tar
tee
ああああああ
いい気持
二悪くない
あたてくれば速い
ingress し駆け上がった大事ですかね英語でした
リンゴジュースはあまり好きじゃないこんなもイラっとされ
ねもう帰るわああやっぱ
皆さんたような
ああああああああ
最新型のロボットアームサメの尾
配置歳エドワードへ nd
ああああああ
[音楽]
me
car
ん oh
5話ところっ
世界はロボットが批判する
ん